comic story and accompanies explain have
teamed up in a partnership with Valiant
Comics to bring you a special series on
Vimeo we'll be exploring the birth of a
super hero through EXO Man O'War what is
an antihero through bloodshot the
diversity in comics through faith and
her team harbinger as of December 17th
you can pre-order the series and then on
the 22nd the 29th and the 5th the videos
will be coming out but wait there's more
a lot of you been asking how you can
help and support both of our channels
while our answer is to create additional
content for you to buy for $4.99 you get
all three of these videos and you'll be
supporting the comic story and and the
comics explained to teams but wait
there's even more no Benny no there's
not any more stuff that's it I guess not
so that's it hope to see you guys on
Vimeo and that is our commercial so in
case you guys didn't catch what that was
basically Robin I've been producing a
special project that you can pre-order
supposedly starting in two days um and
which will be discussing the birth of a
superhero what is an antihero adversity
in comics and tying them all into
Valiant Comics it's a combo thing that
we've been working on it was it's a
project that has been like going on for
like two months and we're finally
getting it out I just robbed robbed
caused all the issues of it just thrown
that out there pretty much I was like I
was like the Assad Rick of this project
yeah it's causing it to be delayed oh
yeah yeah no but you'll see that
commercial going live on both channels
very soon I just got to give this Rob to
do it whatever whatever man whatever all
right guys that's a responsive for today
it's Rob and I once again we charged
ourself extraor Bridget amounts of money
what I don't understand is why Sal gets
to pick how much we charge each other
alright guys today we are gonna be
talking about the amazing most
incredible saga in existence and its
newest episode that is coming out very
soon Harry Potter now how do you feel
about Harry I saw okay so I was watching
the trailer for magical beasts and where
to find them
I didn't see Harry or Ron or Hermione
so I'm not and I can't believe that
Katniss ever green whatever her name is
did not show up either or district 29 so
Everdeen ever
every girl's Everdeen no my Katniss
smokes weed what she's seen all this
blazing up good we are gonna go get the
main president guys but shoot some
arrows do some stuff whatever yeah so
anyway um how do you guys feel about a
little thing that a few people may know
about here let me go ahead and just give
you guys a little psych up on that hold
on hold on hold on wait for it wait for
it wait for it takes a second Oh
somebody somebody asked a hilarious
question I'm right if they were like
like if you could spell out the sound of
a lightsaber like what would that sound
be I there's like hundreds of responses
are just random what are they doing what
they call it wasn't I don't know I see
what just boom I know but like I could
not get over like I was reading through
shattered Empire and I could not get
over how they wrote out like Chewbacca's
like growls and stuff it's hilarious
so in Star Wars The Old Republic I just
hired myself an Ewok companion and they
heal me and it's cool just that it's
cool it's a mercenary Ewok who just
punches everyone it's really cool oh yes
guys I'm well aware that I have a pig in
my hair okay we're gonna talk about Star
Wars and I'm gonna open up with how
addicted I am to Star Wars I'm gonna
talk about this first so I am an
massively addicted to Star Wars so for
this week on the gaming channel I
decided it should be going out real soon
I don't know the schedule over there but
uh a video about the top six app games
that you can get on Star Wars I was like
because I'm playing a whole bunch of
Star Wars commander and bunch of games
let's just find you know three other
ones throw them in this list and do it
and first off end up spending like $200
an app game purchases yesterday because
I love Star Wars which then made me go
hey why don't I play the the old um
what's it called Star Wars over
Republican II see where they're at
I haven't played in forever so I jump
back on that and I think within the
first day I spent like another hundred
dollars on that but now I have a house
and I have
you walk and I have a podracer and I'll
probably never play the game again why
all that stuff near the game for like
five hours that was fun I'm planning
great Commandos awesome I do I am empire
so if you can all die and rob is a
unicorn so do I will be I'll be you know
imagine a unicorn with a lightsaber
Horned God Beasley would that be so what
a treat treat shriek is my new a walk
companion so anyway um so that so not
only that but I also went to like the
Star Wars the party thing at Target over
here at midnight when no one is there
because I live in the mountains so I was
like me and like one other really nerdy
guy we're just there midnight like we're
gonna boys so that's that's not big of a
fan I am never mind the fact that I have
against all better judgment of my entire
team telling me we shouldn't do nothing
but Star Wars have shifted all three
channels to nothing but Star Wars yeah
what what how excited are you guys like
what what why what makes you a giant fan
give me an example now I grew up
watching Star Wars it's a huge thing for
me I I'm really jazzed for the new movie
I mean better than a like a kind of
cautious like battered wife kind of way
is it let's find out I hope not
ya know what Betty's referring to as I
tweeted about how like I don't go to
midnight showings anymore ever since I
went to the midnight showing of
spider-man 3 and I was like wow that
sucks so hard doing this again so but
but the other thing is but the reason
why I'm going to see Star Wars at
midnight is just so I don't so that when
like the when Good Morning America like
wow kylo Ren turning out to be blah blah
blah certainly was a surprise for the
people who saw Star Wars yesterday like
what the hell so I'm just going getting
it out of the way enjoying this you know
what I was like I thought because I do
want to have a talk about I want to
bring our discussion earlier about the
the nature of spoilers nowadays today
yeah I just wanted
hold that thought that should be a good
name yeah because we also have Star Wars
trivia as a backup if we ever run out of
stuff so alright so anyway I'm sorry I
just want to be like like cold certainly
yeah don't yeah I will I will hold that
thought
but yeah so uh then being a huge fan my
my my co-hosts been built me on solid
that is a favorite for later yeah like
see I'm so last yeah you're a Star Trek
fan huh oh wow
that is cool that is very cool tomb yeah
there are yeah this place we're having
both of those will get you in a lot of
trouble yeah the comic book store don't
freak out man you know what you need to
do is you have each one of those in a
holster and then I'm back you have like
a like the sword from Eragon right this
is me I have sons
oh I've blades sword a near the one ring
just I'm unstoppable Opie and a
lightsaber oh yeah but yeah I mean just
I mean I'm a huge Star Wars guy I used
to read the old magazines and speculate
and they collected the old card game
that was that came out and like the like
the mid 90s and you know it's a it's a
very very like special thing to me and
was I got kind of Star Wars fatigue
after the new movies I was like okay I
got a stop because like I said one but
Episode two you're like okay this series
is dead and then all we did for like you
throw a college was just make we just
make fun of and analyze why the movies
are so bad and then red letter media did
their episode 1 review and I'm like
thank you it's done it's dead I can
never I don't know I don't never have to
talk about Star Wars again and then I
just literally like I like I've not
celebrated Star Wars since Disney
purchased it and I was like I think it
might be time to be excited about Star
Wars again but I waited and then when it
turned out like Lawrence Kasdan's
writing in JJ Abrams is directing and I
was like okay I think it's okay and
Kathleen Kennedy is in charge Lucasfilm
like ever all that
good news still is making me like 75%
excited well I I'm in the same boat with
that am I gonna jump on a bandwagon here
but I I agree with you on that one
the first movies it turned turned star
was into more of a joke that attorney
certainly well it turned it into
something else it became something too
cuz there's a lot of people who like
Joel for example is a huge fan of like
Clone Wars and the new rebel show he
just he loves the expanded in the new
expanded universe that I love it too
I love all the new [ __ ] they're cool
like I I value the the good that came
from it but it was good that like needed
to come from the bad like there was this
thing that is you know undisputedly bad
and then they made other things that
were trying to make it less bad but they
still started from a foundation of like
yikes
so I I and also it's just it's not for
it's got what it would have what I've
really learned over times it's not for
me like those three movies are not for
me and you know the like I don't think
they were for anybody I mean clearly
they were for George and his ego and you
know he you know whatever the point
being I like I like oh I like original
Star Wars I have them on laserdisc you
know laserdisc what yeah I have a
laserdisc player it's in my attic but I
still have them on laserdisc yeah all
right well Rob what makes you a super
star wars fan what give me an example of
something reason because Sal just gave
us a life story not really recent but
like I mean I'm like like anybody born
after 1977 like I have seen Star Wars
but at some point in my life you know
like see I'm not as on the fence like I
don't dislike the the prequels as much
as Sal does like the people who are
decent enough I mean you know it's it's
it was interesting like if you can get
through a lot of the nonsense like the
fact that it's like 90% lightsaber
battles like if you can get past all
that stuff and look at the story for it
is it's actually not the worst thing
ever but I mean I you know of course I
stick with four or five and six is being
like the best you know the best films
but for me aside from being like a
casual yeah I like to Star Wars I'll
watch it if it comes on
his 2003 s Knights of the Old Republic
and that's what got me into the Star
Wars lore like that's what got me into
like the expanded universe because it
was like wow like excellently they keep
talking by this guy Exar Kun like who is
Exar Kun you know and bringing his whole
thing and you know going through like
you know the great hyperspace war and
you know that all I kind of stuff like
it was really cool you know and the fact
that it was so built up it's so
organized is what really got me into
being a hardcore Star Wars fan that's
why you know I'm one of the people that
isn't you know as I'm not ranting and
raving about the cancellation of the
expanded universe but I'm sad to see you
go go away I will say this one expanding
universe I had no idea half the crap
that was going on there I also heard it
was from the superfans I'd read it all
like my brother was like that cuz that
was way to expand it for me to become a
part of I'm like yeah it was
overwhelming there's no question about
it was just it was too it was too much I
mean that's why Disney rebooted that was
one of the core reasons well it also
what great what great money potential so
just go like okay throw it all out now I
can start all over again down mine the
same exact field but within it you know
with the totally different perspective
yeah well that was that was kind of the
kicker is like I was doing a periscope
and somebody was like hey Rob can you
make a video explain the differences
between like the expanded universe and
the new Canon and I was like are you
serious has decades of stuff another one
I told him I was like you're talking
about almost 30 to 40 years worth of
history that ranges everything from like
the origin of the Republic to like when
Luke Skywalker fell to the dark side
after afterward it like like every if it
if it exists there is a story for it and
I was like that's way too much to cover
well that is the problem of the original
expanding universe I'm not saying it was
bad but for them to try and get back
into the entire universe for them to be
like we're gonna make some new stories
as tough there was almost nothing left
for them to do that hadn't already been
established somewhere yeah which is
where the problems are gonna come in
because it was kind of like oh well we
want to touch on what happens to Luke
afterwards oh no we know what happens to
Luke afterwards he falls to the dark
side he isn't going to tomorrow they end
up having a son die yeah exactly
this his only option was to do like
10,000 years in the super future or to
reboot the whole thing it makes it make
sense I mean you know if Disney's gonna
buy
out star wars you know they say we're
going to take over this franchise it
makes sense that they would say you know
we're going to have to effectively
retcon things yes if you look at the
entire I mean let's say for example that
they said okay let's make a movie about
something in the expanded universe well
then what do you what do you make a
movie on yeah I mean what do you do you
know and even then you know the problem
is that that they faced was that even
within Lucas's own camp even within like
Lucasfilm there were people who argued
over what was official and what was it
Lucas was like in the movies it's
official and it's not in the movies it's
not official and people were like well I
mean there's other stuff that counts you
know and so even Lucasfilm itself
couldn't agree on what was considered
Canon and what wasn't and so the easiest
thing to do was to just come along and
say you know what let's just wipe it all
and start and start over again and
create their own expanded universe and
they're doing well yeah the good thing
is even though they're through all this
like stuff people enjoyed away
number one doesn't make them go away you
can still enjoy them and read them and
them and like Marvel just released like
those omnibus 'iz of the old like marvel
prints of Star Wars that's really cool
I'm sure the Dark Horse stuff will be
available in the future I don't know why
that's the kind of what I love about
they're doing their cuz dizzy wasn't
just like throw all that out was never
being printed again all becoming super
close they were like no it's it's still
there if you want to have that
Elseworlds kind of like it happened in
the original timeline yeah once they
feel like cashing in on that they can
start yeah they can release like Star
Wars alternates or whatever they want it
I think they actually have a term for it
where it's like if legends the alleged
Star Wars legends it made-up [ __ ] in
this diverse universe basically what it
is at this point yeah
well the funny thing too is if you go
and like and watch the show this is
something that I notice I don't know how
many people noticed it but if you go and
watch the trailers there's no reference
to the word Seth anywhere
no at any point in the original trilogy
there there is but there's no word they
never say safe they don't say how do you
know those movies like the back of my
hand yeah they do they never would ever
like and that's a cool thing because Han
Solo says he says that that all that was
true the Jedi and the dark side yeah and
so my
is what did--what Dizzy's gonna do going
forward is you're gonna say there's the
Jedi and then there's people who are
corrupted that don't have a name they're
just like fallen Jedi which is how it
started it started as like fallen Jedi
and then like his fur came around later
on
yeah the term used to be called Dark
Jedi or like okay there's dark jedi and
then there's Jedi and they always I mean
the expanding universe always said that
Vader was the Dark Lord of the Sith the
word seyth had been had been established
but it was never said in the original
movies but they did always establish
that Vader was the Dark Lord of the Sith
it's just that nobody ever knew what the
hell that meant like what are the Sith
and how come Vader's in charge of them
he doesn't even to be in charge of
anything Lincoln yes Corbin is expensi
Horman's expands universe you know that
came around God well I think what's
something like a novel it came around
and it said that originally the Dark
Jedi
that Jedi fell from the light side were
cast out and eventually when they went
to Corbin where they encountered like
the race there was actually a race of
crais's yeah yeah yeah and then and they
they didn't really like merge with him
so much as they you know adopted their
ability to tap into the dark side of
whatever and then came back as accurate
like calling themselves Seth exactly
yeah like that that's where Corbin and
all that kind of stuff came from
that's all expanded universe stuff and
that's why it's so awesome is because
even you know if you expanded universe
going you have to return the Jedi you
have the Yuuzhan Vong you had the death
of Chewbacca you had all kinds a
difference nobody liked everybody that's
funny they also had a thing called Lucas
books where like if it was a Lucas book
theoretically or officially George Lucas
approved that story there were some
stories that were in the expanding
universe that were not technically part
of Canon but then there were other ones
that George Lucas had personally signed
off on that were part of Canada they got
confusing and but I like the fact that
like a lot of those books came with like
a timeline in them that told you like
where it took place in the Star Wars
universe and what significant events had
taken place in like with with respect to
your story wasn't that the official
George Lucas timeline and in the
expanded universe alternate timeline
that's pretty much how they looked at it
before
well George looked at I mean like
officially Lucasfilm was like no the
expand universes that have this like
bran
are also part of the whole thing but
Lucas when he would do interviews would
say well to me the only thing that is
canon are the three movies yeah so that
was always like a source of contention
for people where they're like wait a
minute
like according to Lucas like that you
know you you accorded the company you
said that this all takes place in st.
continuity but Lucas says that they're
not and then when he made the three
movies and people said well wait a
minute we've actually we actually have
documentation and art that proves that
everything you're saying in the three
movies is not true he was like well no
that's all garbage now because I movie
well then and and that's kind of the
funny thing is you know for a lot of
fans that's that's why you know for
those of you guys who are watching this
why shouldn't there like that's one of
the reasons why so many fans were so
angry about the cancellation of the
expanded universe because it wasn't
necessarily the fact that there was like
well stories like the origin of Han Solo
trilogy are gone now it was stuff like
so much effort was put into it like you
had rules you've had guidelines you know
if the expanded universe were still in
existence right now and or listen we
wind back to 2011 or something like that
and Sal and I start writing novels
there are rules we have to follow one we
have to read the entire expanded
universe that's right it's because we
can't write something that contradicts
what's already there like you know if
you know when dark horse
Dark Horse Road dark empire at the dark
Empire trilogy and they said that they
saw was that Emperor Palpatine was
actually just a Sith Lord jumping from
body to body yeah exactly and then Luke
Skywalker became as apprentice fell to
the dark side if we came around and
wrote a novel they contradicted that it
would be rejected by the expanding
universe community as a whole we would
have waste our time writing an entire
line yeah and so it was it was so it was
so well organized there was so much
effort put into it and it was really
just a grassroots campaign and the fact
that you know it came around you know
Disney came around and said nope all
your work is gone out the window it
doesn't it's not official anymore
doesn't apply
yeah people were angry people are upset
makes sense you know cuz you have people
that hate spent so much time reading
about it and building it and the only
ones I'm really sad to lose honestly our
heir to the Empire shadows the Empire
and dark yeah come on Starkiller yeah
the first was very cool
yeah ignore the second one let's birth
if we can pick a Jew's let's go with the
first ones and continuity that second
one with the clone [ __ ] stuff like
like you look hell drama I think was the
first Jedi to fall to the dark side and
go back to the light side and so you had
really cool stories of moments like that
you know revin was cool revin didn't go
down inside though I'm saying oh yeah
well I mean Old Republic he's currently
like the big baddie at least what I'm
reading at all the stuff have you never
read you never play match the order
public we're talking about what about
Kyle Rayner is the Green Lantern is it a
cow Renner has a torn car the dark
forces games like dark forces dark
forces to Jedi Knight dark forces three
Jedi Knight two and then dark forces for
Jedi Knight three Dark One
like they all had subtitles but yeah I
loved the dark we're doing the bouncing
back and forth thing in revin everyone
in the cut and the thing is saying they
definitely revin came back to the light
side I don't know how that is because in
Old Republic currently rabbit I get
you're right i far as I know all over
probably is a thousand years before
Knights of the Old Republic so I really
don't know like I came back to the game
to like the current storyline - revin is
the bad guy I'm like I don't know how
that works
no it's worth as far as he the official
well I mean even then like my experience
with revin is limited to the night
Scioli Republic so I don't know if
there's if there were any novels in the
expand universe that pick up after that
now as I know reven like disappeared to
the depths of space and never came back
- surrender whoever's - friend are yeah
for his annotation in his Mara Mara Mara
Marg a wife yeah and the Emperor's
right-hand or something
yeah or fists I remember so okay so I
think long story short we're like we
like Star Wars and I think we're all
gonna miss the expanding universe even I
mean I don't think anyone here read and
got a part of everything no not by a
long shot
like we all have it hard to be liked
yeah no one speak of Jar Jar Binks can
be retcon down that'd be really cool Jar
Jar Binks as you would your pick to your
beard like nine so the topic because we
talked about that and what kind of end
this with how excited we are about Star
Wars well with their own little
theorycrafting of a Star Wars The Force
awakens but I want we got into an
interesting debate earlier and I'm
pretty sure I saw was mad at me magician
the way he was typing get angry typing I
get this feeling like like that the
letters were coming across red and angry
and shaky that's a new feature I have so
so I don't wanna get you guys opinions
about this spoilers in current media
period because Star Wars isn't the first
thing we also had the issue with like I
used a great example of Supergirl
there's another she Starla but the
minute before I go into that let me
explain what I'm talking about here so
Sal put out if anybody tweets me that
spoilers of the movie you will be banned
i toid her wrong with it and I said I
think what Darth Vader is Luke's father
as well I think I said yeah yeah I don't
remember I was like if somebody said
Vader was Luke's father which is like
huh okay
exactly but then of course everyone jump
to the bandwagon of the joke spoiler
adding jokes spoilers to it yes which of
course which is fine but it wasn't like
it wasn't just enough that people were
like hey I'm joking how how we're
appalled part of the gang it was also
like is this a spoiler Sal like is this
and it's like [ __ ] you so anyway look
what this turned into you was Sal
hitting up in our chat do they have a
little chat we will discuss time to talk
about the topics today yeah and Sally
mentioned that everyone's tormenting him
about the spoiler thing because I
incited the whole thing which is why I
said I think Rob misawa's angrily typing
at this point I said but they were
bandwagoning you're you so I draw I'd
not jokingly but I was like in my
opinion in this day and age if you don't
want spoilers you need to avoid things
like social media YouTube stuff like
that
and the reason is simple our job is
social media YouTube is a form of social
media it's all kinds of social media
it's what we do and the problem is and I
learned this a long time ago a great
example is Metal Gear Solid 5 phantom
pain came out my channel gaming channels
primarily focused around Metal Gear
Solid stuff before the game even came
out the ending was spoiled for me in the
comments that's [ __ ] right like the
big reveal it was already so I'm not
gonna put it here in case somebody still
hasn't played phantom pain just say the
big reveal I'm sure that I mean we get
the gist it's a huge reveal but anyway
I'm saying what I'm getting at is it was
revealed ahead of time so I took a
stance a long time ago that if there's
something I really want to avoid
spoilers on I need to avoid social media
my comments all that kind of stuff yeah
so I told Sal that I'm like in our line
of work if you don't want to spoil it or
something you need to stay off your
social media yeah it sounds responsible
I'm gonna keep doing it the way I want
to do it which is banned people who mess
things up for me but what what that does
is it brings into the discussion the
nature of spoilers nowadays because even
shows like Supergirl their official
Twitter
Supergirl CBS now I watch all my shows
the next day digitally on Hulu and stuff
like that I log on to my Twitter the
morning after the mahkum at a martian
manhunter reveal and they are literally
showing a gift of the scene of hank
henshaw turning are spoilers turn here
it's hurting into the martian manhunter
yeah i mean like it's front and center
from them officially and Batman vs
Superman I don't think anyone out here
can argue that and we know the majority
the story at this point
yeah I mean it's literally like
beginning middle and end like yes the
movie set up payoff conclusion like
that's them that's the trailer no but we
were saying like I was saying that the
reason why they're doing that
like why CBS ruined their own show and
why BBS is like here's doomsday is
because they're like but they want to
have possession over their own material
like that maybe Superman is like we're
gonna show you doomsday because we don't
want you to find out Doomsday's in the
movie from a freaking toy release like
which is because you know those toys are
gonna come out like months before the
movie does or the very least the Toy
Fair will happen and people take a
million pictures
toys and then release them I mean like
their you know that scene where Batman
has like the trenchcoat and there's
there might be parademons and stuff
right we know what that is because of a
Toy Fair like I'm not gonna say what it
is but they're like if you look up toys
and stuff we know what it is right but
like and they want to have possession
over their own things CBS is like if you
didn't watch the show you're gonna find
out about hank henshaw immediately from
a million sources that aren't us so I
guess we'll just release it ourselves
and it sucks that they feel they need to
do that well and that's it goes to the
question though at what point did the
spoiler world cheat because he used to
be let's say great example lost do you
really lost hmm if you didn't if you
didn't watch lost don't you freak and
tell me what the hell happened that
night but now here come normal like oh
it's true like and and it's fair to have
a reaction like you know you're at the
water cooler like have you caught the
last episode of lost at least preface
your conversation with that but you also
can't be like like the the spoiler the
joke of spoilers of like Luke is you
know Vader's son like her her her it was
30 years ago
you can't like there's a statute of
limitations on these things you know
right like then and and that's fair and
if you choose to live in a bubble where
you know like well you know I'm not
really making it like okay let's say
that like I'm really busy
and I don't want to see force awakens
full-price with a lot of people so my
plan is I'm gonna see it in February at
a matinee and I'm trying to and I'm
trying to avoid spoilers that's on you
that is where it's like you then then
you need to create an environment where
you cannot ever find out what happens
but I think it's fair to bubble is
contained there to ask that people show
a little effing decorum when the movie
isn't out yet if I haven't seen it
because no one has except people with
exclusive access or the British because
it came out like what yesterday but if
you exclusive access that's that's good
for you you get that's against your
torch to hold like you can lord it over
everybody I know what happens
but like to seek people out and ruin
things for them that is a dick move
whether it's whether whether we are
youtubers or podcasters or you know e
news correspondents or newspaper like
editors the fact is that's a dick move
and I shouldn't be held responsible for
the machinations and actions of socially
[ __ ] people no III don't I don't
argue that it's a [ __ ] move no one
should be contacting you and I agree
like the nature of the spoiler was
people were tweeting at me
just the information they felt would be
hilarious run by the way as I understand
it they were fake I don't know that
right you know and I'm not denying that
people are being [ __ ] with that I
mean that that's literally what it is I
mean that's the epitome of a troll that
somebody tried like the comment of Metal
Gear Solid in my comments that's G dick
that's all he was doing like the comment
was not like he didn't go into a whole
theory it wasn't him trying to ever
discussion with me preface it by saying
like listen I wanna I want an engaging
conversation in your you know in your
house so I'm going to do that but here's
a spoiler tag heuer tag which is always
I think is the fairest way to do it
early on yeah cuz then you can go oh and
then just avoid the entire world that
that is like if you like I'm not gonna
go on reddit for the next three days
that's the point I won't ask the
comments though cuz I mean I think every
one of the comments agrees that's a
[ __ ] ish to do yeah boil somebody
you know is gonna watch it or somebody
in the feel they're gonna watch it that
is a [ __ ] move to do but especially
in our area because I'm no I know people
who do this about like when Game of
Thrones airs stay for the next day you
know but if but it was also in our world
like an hour in our environment like
jessica jones is a perfect example
because jessica jones whole shows out
you know that there's at least a
thousand people who watched the last
episode first oh yeah yeah yeah and then
made a video about like that's a lot of
people do like they they watch the last
they watch the last episode then they go
through they go online and
do Google search like things I missed in
Jessica Jones and then make videos based
on that I know people who do that you're
like his name is comics explained and I
know we know you did we know you did
yeah anyway I wanted to ask everyone is
now in here's and here's where this is
what the one talk about the nature of
spoilers changing do you think and I ask
you and ask you Rob and I asked the
comments do you think that sport
avoiding spoilers is now more in the
hands of the viewer himself like you
said make your own bubble yeah as
opposed to the old days where it was you
shouldn't even be talking to me because
we are in a day and age where you're
gonna have trolls and you're going to
people purposely trying to spoil your
experience they are purposely going to
be doing that yes so is it now in our
hands to avoid like okay I'm comes out
in Britain tomorrow and you're came out
already but it comes out here on like
Thursday night okay so so it gave
example I'm gonna say on and just to eat
whatever comes my way because I'm gonna
have to but a great example is you you
don't want spoilers now I'm asking the
comments and you guys and I kind of know
your opinion cuz we've already discussed
this okay you already know you what you
want to do yeah do you feel that it is
now on the person trying to avoid the
spoilers not even salan general I'm
talking like somebody for Game of
Thrones yeah to avoid all of this social
media feeds until they can watch it or
do you think it's still completely an
honor system of don't be a dick to me
because I think we're at a point now
where that's kind of out the window
everyone's gonna be a dick a thousand
people will be not a dick to you and
then one guy will be a dick and it's
spoiled that's it yes well it takes one
yeah like I mean we'll let's well while
we're waiting for the chat to get this
answer or get this question and the
formulate your answer I mean the fact is
it's always on you yeah like it's always
beholden to a person who has all their
faculties to have decorum in any
situation whether it's yelling fire in a
theatre whether it's not stabbing
someone who you're having an argument
with you know whether it's like it's
you're always in some way restraining
yourself from
taking of your own accord because we
live in a society now the Internet of
course gives people license or at least
gives people to believe they have a
license to do whatever they want
whenever they want to with no
repercussions because they live in an
anonymous environment like they say
things that they would never say in
public because they know that they can
never be reprimanded for it or they can
ever be held accountable for it but and
while the layers are peeled back of
self-awareness to the point where maybe
when they first started it they knew
they wouldn't they shouldn't do it but
they do it because it makes them feel a
certain way the more they do it the more
desensitize they become to it to the
point where not only does it become
second nature but I think they don't
even understand the repercussions of
what they do and they don't understand
that they shouldn't do it I think that
there's actually like almost like a
regression the more you do it and so
there are trolls out there who literally
live in a world where they're like and
this is what I do and if they were
called out on it they have an initial
reaction which is like to make fun of
you but they don't they don't let it
penetrate to the point where they can
understand like yeah oh I actually do
live in a society where I have to I I
have to give up you know whether it's my
own personal indulgence or you know
anything in order to let someone else
function you know it's just like we were
just I just feel a thing today this has
nothing to do with it but I was just so
nothing today of a couple that did a
proposal in the middle of a highway I
mean during morning rush hour traffic
yeah I saw that
right and they and people were honking
and their friends who were filming it
were like look at everyone like
congratulating you they're not
congratulating you right there beeping
at you because you're an idiot and
you're ruining their day there was a
woman who needed an emergency c-section
in an ambulance that was also being held
up in that situation and I don't think
it even registered to them that they
could live in a world where they were
inconveniencing anybody or even if they
did they were like of course I'm
inconveniencing anybody this is my movie
look at the star of my movie and it's
all on me and you're like a bit part or
a supporting character or an extra it's
why whatever like have you guys ever
been in a movie theater and someone's
talking and you give him a look or you
actually say like hey quiet
and they look at you like you're the one
being wrong right like how dare you
question me how dare you and it's I
think it's legitimately like like if you
were in a scene with an actor and you're
you know like you're in you're in Star
Wars right and Harrison Ford's acting
and you're a stormtrooper and then you
go like hey and soullow why don't you
shut up and hansel it looks at you like
what's this stormtrooper doing
you're not the movie ain't called
stormtrooper xt xt v 2k is gonna have a
special day the movies about me you know
but and that's the reaction that we get
and I think it's just this this this
narcissist kind of desensitization that
the Internet provides now that quit now
why I think there's a certain amount of
elitism that comes with it also because
I actually yeah this reminds me of ok so
there's an anime that came up in Adult
Swim it's called that's somebody's
periscope Jefferson is lie though this
reminds me because I remember this
particular particular comment now
there's a an anime that came out called
a comic on kill and it's about a serious
people they don't want strap whatever
it's an anime doesn't really matter when
I talk about that right now but what
happened was I was what I've read the
mangas I know the story for it right if
somebody decided to tweet hashtag a
spoiler for the end of the series but
the excuse of well I saw the crunchyroll
you should have to know that is that is
an elitism where it's like I have
exclusive access it's definitely I mean
you're gonna see an ass load of force
awakens spoilers because people are from
overseas they watch they know the
Americans of course there's another like
whole thing where it's like oh let's
let's screw over the Americans give them
a hard time but like there's this whole
like thing words like I have exclusive
access I mean well yeah not the kind of
what's gonna happen more Star Wars this
is why I'm going to avoid Twitter until
I get to see mine Friday afternoon
people well I saw the midnight showing
it Thursday you should too right exactly
and the fact is vigilance is the price
that we pay for being intelligent people
and I don't mean like more intelligent
than you I'm saying more intelligent
than the troll
who think that whose brains are damaged
by their self-indulgence yeah and
vigilance is like what is that it just
means we have to be aware we need to be
more careful and that sucks like the
fact is if you have exclusive access you
have a responsibility it's like great
power great responsibility like you have
a responsibility to not ruin it for
people but I is us as an intelligent
person have to also recognize that
there's a huge subset of the population
who doesn't care or doesn't understand
and they're going to do it anyway so
I've got to take steps right now I also
see that people you know but the fact is
it's also my Twitter it's my prerogative
I get to say like hey if you try to ruin
it for me it means you're a [ __ ] and
I'm gonna but I'm gonna ban you ya know
when we had our suit a little you know I
wouldn't really call it an argument cuz
just ideas ya know and I never once said
you're wrong don't do it though I know
exactly cuz you are in any way shape or
form and I know as some people are
saying like when I open this
conversation it sound like I was trying
to prove myself right I'm not everyone
can have their own opinion I personally
am in the boat right now where I'm just
accepting them all because I don't feel
like trying to fend them off I hide
things it really depends on what it is
you know like if it was Harry Potter
which I find cool but don't obsess over
I don't care like it's not gonna ruin it
for me Jessica Jones I rent the comic I
know the show's gonna end similarly to
the comic so I'm not that upset if I see
a Jessica Jones spoiler yeah it always
it important to you this is well it's
also like Jesse Jones a show it's it's
based off comic this is a thing that
they made that we weren't ever really
gonna ever get it's the first of four
it's the first Star Wars sequel that I
actually want so technically I've been
waiting since like the 80s for this and
it's you know so it means something it
means more to me so yes I'm gonna I'm
gonna have more priority on it and end
on and I'm gonna try and safeguard the
spoilers there but a pressure I preserve
that experience but what's you know
what's hilarious is you imagine like
when the original trailer when the
original prequels came out I think we're
boring Rob he's looking yeah no he's
like
all my layers listen to what you're
saying I was online in 1999 and I I did
not see any spoilers for Phantom Menace
and I think if I had I might've gone
opening freaking day yeah but it's funny
because I remember when I first saw it I
was like that Wow okay that mm-hmm
and I heard people talking about like oh
boy I can't wait to go see it and I'm
like enjoy like I'm not gonna ruin the
movie for them it didn't even occur to
me to try and wreck it for them now
that's just a difference because I
remember back then I went to see Phantom
Menace and the next day was not like I
gotta go tell everyone about though it
was exactly have you seen it no go see
we're talking tomorrow I'm gonna talk
about this so you need to go or I'll go
away the reality is like if I'm if I'm
in the minority yeah then I'll extricate
myself from society well I did that with
Jessica Jones I still I'm gonna say
right now I intend to don't worry I'm
taking next week off we've got all our
videos lined up for next week I'm
already good to go I'm gonna watch it
finally but I still have it and I
eventually was like look I I just can't
avoid spoilers anymore just talk just we
gotta do the show you know right right
even when we were like okay let's talk
about the end you left like you you do
you unplugged which is smart and like
but you also told us we'll talk about
the show so I don't feel bad doesn't do
anything wrong with everyone wanted to
see your opinions on it and I thought it
wasn't was it their fault that I hadn't
watched it yet yeah I think a pretty
good job of avoiding stuff but I know
it's base in the comics so I already to
kind of know where who's commit and
what's true but I also I felt like a
jackass watching Jessica Jones um in a
hurry you know like I wanted to enjoy it
at my pace which is like it's a freaking
13 to 14 episode show like however long
it was I remember because I watched it
all so like I but I wanted to watch it
and just enjoy thankfully I gave myself
the luxury I did avoid spoilers I did
avoid Twitter and I tried not to
thankfully it also wasn't an
international freakin phenomenon Jessica
Jones this great show but it also didn't
like it's not a five billion dollar
franchise before a single frame of
animation has been released yet so I you
know I could also carefully avoid
jessica jones by just
simply not going to the Jessica Jones
subreddit or whatever but like you know
I also died did feel that pressure but
it's like we're a comp a channel I
understand that we're a conflict Channel
Star Wars may be a comic book the force
awakens is a movie not a movie channel
channel like we're you know we talk
about movies but like that's not our
purview right so it to expect us to see
the force awakens like for it's expect
me to fly to England and watch it now
and then come back and have that
information is unrealistic
I want to I'd be that'd be the coolest
thing in the world I first gave it away
that's got the free tickets oh that yeah
Witham Foust isn't here today cuz we
kicked him off guys
yeah just saying you didn't feel
comfortable we were like we're like hey
you didn't you had never seen any Star
Wars we should talk about it he's like
that would not be a conversation no no
no he did try yeah I will give him
credit he watched the first episode
episode one and it was like that was a
horrible movie I am NOT what he did not
do what I suggested we just watch the
originals and then maybe watch the next
role gene maybe if you're a child I
would not recommend that because no so
alright let's take a two-second breather
because we are trying to get into the
swing of Jamie's proper plug the Percy's
here but I'd like to let you guys know
about Darby pop publishing and their
books sidekick tits on the screen right
now sidekick does a great story about
superheroes and and their sidekicks and
them treating their sidekicks horribly
and the sidekicks going on just right
like literally going on strike it's a
cool idea cool a cool premise and you
can check it out a comiXology right now
the book is called sidekick I think I've
depend down a little bit so you guys can
see it properly the other thing sidekick
awesome book from Darby pop publishing
one of the indie book publishers that we
are trying to help kind of get going
here alright below and back to our
discussion see I'm just working on a
book just like that I'm like oh I'm
getting into the flow of this that was
very seamless mostly marks here's here's
a kicker when it comes to like spoilers
if we were like if we didn't do what we
did
I'd say Sal has a legitimate case but by
virtue of being youtubers especially
youtubers that
deal with comic books in geek culture
really popular elements we're gonna be
we're gonna see we're gonna be you know
blasted by more spoiler stuff than
anybody else
partly because what we do draws the
attention of people who like to troll
and also because of the fact that some
of our fans just literally want to tell
us what happened you know yeah it's
Rob's on my side
welcome ladies maybe it's important to
social awkwardness because they don't
they don't I mean maybe a slight you
know sound said they don't register the
outdoor that there is a level of you
know there's a level there's a lot of
demarcation there there's what's
appropriate and inappropriate when it
comes to you know spoiling things but
the instant that and and if I'm gonna be
quite frank you know my rule is that if
something comes out within 24 hours
everything's everything's on the field
you can you know I would not want to
intentionally go out and you know I
wouldn't send you a tweet and say hey
sound like did you believe that like
Darth Vader dies at the end of Return of
the Jedi I wouldn't I wouldn't like you
know tweet that out to you I think you
were part of the tag too cuz you banned
him I think it was like a spoiler I feel
like can you guys believe this like that
is a goddamn spoiler like yeah well but
to me like it's it's it I'm kind of kind
of in the middle of the road here
binney's right when you say that it's
part and parcel to being in a career
field where you deal with with social
media more so because we we can't escape
social mean we can't we can't walk like
it's not like we could shut down our
Twitter and walk away I mean I got it
but it would be but we can but we
shouldn't what we can't okay I should
not it is in a in a sense a form of
intimidation it is it is a form of like
forcing you to shy away from your
livelihood when you when you under
normal circumstances would not because
of the feelings of another person if we
were like it like on Twitter if I'm
subscribed to like comic resources and
bleeding cool and I'm watching their
feed and I get spoilers from that that's
on me because that's my job
I'm looking at these people trying to
get information and stuff like that like
like I they're my colleagues in a sense
and we there a news source they're
trying their prerogative to get the
views right and they're gonna try and do
that through any means possible it's one
thing for me to passively get spoilers
it's another thing entirely to be
aggressively assaulted with spoilers
I'll let me thank you with a crazy
experience Isley assaulted with spoilers
that's what it was it was a person who
was like who's who sent me four tweets
in a row of just key spoilers oh yeah
this this morning so like when I woke up
they were there waiting for me like a
lunatic so and by the way once again
they're fake but not funny sorry like I
hate to be the one to tell you that
that's not funny and not cool but no one
will like no one's gonna do it but
remember that remember that movie
remember that show Firefly and how great
it was and how it died and then I didn't
know where they made this movie about it
called serenity nobody watched it and
nobody cared and it made like half the
money back before the movie came out the
day before like the day before I saw it
and by the way before the movie came out
I movie came out in September I saw it
in June because I had access to [ __ ] so
but but in May somebody else got access
to it and they wrote a review of it and
they said it's a non-spoiler review so I
was like cool I will read this
non-spoiler review I'm going to spoil
serenity now for you so dont't know what
happens mute me and I will wave at you
in case by the way the movie has been
dead for six years so or almost so but
they tried to revive it with a comic now
yeah like with like five comics and each
one worse than the last one but uh
surrett but the opening paragraph was in
spite of the fact that two of our main
characters died now the review does not
say who dies but two of the main
characters die and so
that's if love like six of them there's
only well there's only yeah there's only
nine of those people and they're all
intro important and wonderful now of
their own huge [ __ ] like you know fan
followings so I know that I claim II
just closed it I never found that
interview again by the way but I closed
it and then I was like yeah I went to
that movie with a completely singular I
will say the only way the spoilers have
enhanced my what my viewing experience
was because I got that piece of spoilers
by the way no wait no yeah because I got
that I'm watching this movie going who's
it gonna be who's it gonna be
and then one person bout dies and I go
oh god there's only one laughs it was
not the person I expected so I'm I'm in
this movie and I by the way I didn't
tell anybody else so I saw this movie
like six other people were sitting there
and they're like this is gonna be great
and I'm like you have no idea what's
coming it's like God came before me
right before the next day and they're
like hey don't tell anybody but I'm
ended in the world at six o'clock and
then who so everyone's like who can that
I'm dumb don't think I'm gonna invest in
a 401k I'm like I wouldn't what's coming
it's just but so but what a dick move
what a lunatic I mean overall I think
the statute of limitations at least for
us in our field is leave me the hell
alone on the weekend if I don't catch an
opening weekend find whatever it's my
own prerogative exactly like if I miss
it then I'm in well if I missed it right
if like if force awakens comes out and
then I'm busy and I don't see it and
it's Tuesday or Monday then I'm gonna
know that I'm walking on a minefield
like I will deliberately be like no I'm
not gonna watch anything or read
anything and I'll have to be a jackass
and when I go into a drugstore go
everyone
don't tell me what happened in Star Wars
but it's it's it's it's it's - it's
Tuesday look come on oh yeah I agree
um and that's and that's basically I
mean with Star Wars I'm already
expecting to wake up Friday morning
having not seen the movie yet Oh in the
opening like the knee or that the Good
Morning America be like well that was
crazy yeah I know there's
reviews out there's going to be the
tweets I'll probably gonna have a
thousand notifications of the juicy that
kylo Ren was actually legitimately I
remove my newsfeed for my phone I will
not check Twitter that day you know I'm
just gonna you know let's go to go well
can you believe that sex scene would
chewy and hard like what not going
anybody watching if you could remember
to tweet me tweet that to me Friday
morning just to you can you believe that
sex scene I will give you a barista to
spoil that for me no I stick by the
state by the argument that when it comes
to what we do spoilers are unavoidable
there's there's no possible way to have
a film as big as this especially being
what it is you know it'd be different if
this was some giant George Clooney film
like Michael Clayton or something like
that people were like oh it's gonna be
an amazing film like this is literally
geek culture you've got Star Wars films
you've got Star Wars comic books based
on Marvel Comics you know like I've done
videos on Star Wars comics like
obviously Star Wars is an intricate part
of what we do or at least only intricate
insofar that we talk about comics but
you know it's an unavoidable aspect of
being a youtuber being involved in
social media things are gonna be spoiled
so I would say that for us in particular
the impetus is more on us than it is on
other people to avoid well yes and
that's like saying that you live in a
war zone so if you get shot or stabbed
that's really on you be that as it may
you live in it you live in a crappy town
and if you get stabbed like listen have
you seen this the knife rates like it's
pretty bad so you don't watch beholdin
to the person who is a lunatic like
yours should it be that like maybe we
should have a higher expectation of
humanity well we should but we don't
that's a problem and I kind of like both
ways yeah you shouldn't have been
stabbed but it's also partially and you
were living in that part of town like
you have other options accept it so like
you don't always have other options as
if your associate like if you're
socially
downtrodden if you were economically
downtrodden if it all you have is access
to this and you're trying to eke out a
living let's say like you it's your one
day off and you're trying to get to work
or you're taking the bus or you're
walking through a crappy area because
you worked late to make extra money to
like you know provide for your family
like there's any number of examples you
can use to show here's a person who
didn't have it coming that got left over
anyway and it's really not their fault
yeah but that's I mean that's really
heavy-handed like our situations like
you could literally just not sign into
Twitter for a week right except that
like that yeah well even you are
comparing death to not right I'm using a
larger example to illustrate a simple
point which is simply that like it's
Tuesday there are they shouldn't even be
spoilers for this movie yet yeah but if
the spoilers been released in the world
I mean it's one thing if you say like
well ok the film came out today in a
country somewhere then if you look at it
to believe that what you're being told
could be a spoiler if the film has not
been released publicly anywhere then you
can probably dismiss it and say there's
there's no possible way that's a spoiler
but right you know what yes but I
shouldn't be exposed to them regardless
I'm speaking generally you think that
I'm like Trent pocos and your argument
I'm just saying like I don't think I
think you're arguing is felonious I
don't think you're actually making it or
what I'm saying is what you're doing is
you're saying you're walking out into
the world and say there are a million
people from a million different walks of
life you know that have a million
different viewpoints on how they want to
live their lives and they should all
take into account my beliefs and the
beliefs of everyone out let me tell you
somethin if everybody in the world cared
about everybody else like the broad
couldn't function like I mean I don't
know what to tell you in a world of
social media
I was all about asking you to tell me
anything but like more or more to the
point it's it's not that I'm asking
everyone to do one certain thing I'm
simply saying I expect better of
humanity you're
people not to spoil a movie for you that
is a certain thing well okay Rob yeah
yeah that's what I'm asking Rob one yeah
all right I'm not Portland trivia is
like Betty Sue's bored I'm listening I'm
a bigger Paula thousand people should be
more courteous I agree with you man but
what I'm saying is it there's it in
between that's the whole art okay you're
making that I agree with you but that's
armchair philosophy so okay so what I
now realize those we have 200 people
watching us right yeah we have 200
people that we've now armed with this al
is gonna hate your guts if you try and
spoil stuff we're so out of these 200 if
one of them is a troll like I'm
disabling all comments on my videos for
the next three days I'm not signing in a
Twitter it's like I'm not doing scopes
well I think this conversation is a
weird turn so let's end this with your
table like accept what you're set it up
the new movie I'm excited to find out
what the hell kylo Ren is because like
they're like he's not sick he's not safe
I do care about kylo Ren don't know who
he is it's like there's they're selling
dolls of this guy and people are you
waiting in the line to get your bb-8 you
don't even know who he is he could be
the Dark Lord of the Sith all we know
like they're freaking the hell out
making dbm like the new kids toy
and I'm like watch the movies gonna come
out and he's like the evil droid the
little Death Star and he just floats
into the air and he fires into buildings
and explodes
thank you audio guy 88 for subscribing
but like ya know like I I honestly don't
the only thing I'm excited for is the
fact that like that it exists there's
that there's some level of enthusiasm
behind it and there's some
level of quality control employees at
George Lucas's not making it that's the
thing like I do knowing knowing that he
actually had some ideas and they said no
makes me even at work site oh yeah
apparently he like he they invite him on
the set he was like oh you could do this
this net and they were like yeah no
thanks George last time you did that you
made these three horrible things so yeah
yeah they're using practical effects
that'll be cool yeah they're actually
going to miss the whole movies not gonna
be feeling in front of a green screen
yeah so the actors maybe like will care
about what happens yeah I mean like I'm
excited to see what happens I'm sad to
see the old crew again and see where
they've been yeah that's like the thing
I want to see Luke I want to see Han I
wanna see Leia
you know they don't come back for
episode 8 it's gonna be cool to see
Ritter yeah and I hope the new kids are
great yeah I think they will be for what
I could tell I think I think they're
gonna be pretty solid I've never seen
any of them act so I long is that none
of them are Annie right it's funny
because like these are it unlike the new
trilogy or the the prequel trilogy I've
never seen any of the people who are
like the new guard mm-hmm anything now I
know they've been in stuff but yeah
that's awesome but like I see Natalie
Portman act I saw Hayden Christensen act
I've seen your McGregor active scene
Lane it like I knew all these people so
seeing this new cast is like how awesome
it's a totally clean slate I don't I've
never seen easy really do a damn thing
so he's great there's actually a really
funny moment if he goes I can watch
episode 3 there's a funny moment when
r2d2 is fighting those little droids on
the ship and you can look at Hayden
Christensen reciting his line and like
you can spot the moment when he's like
my career is over like a couple things
and then he was in jumper after that but
like yeah yeah nobody nobody wanted to
see that no but it's cause of Hayden
Christensen no jumpers it's not bad at
all
I also heard it was supposed to be like
a series and then they were like
made like $5 hurts know that the jumper
book was it was really really good like
the kid Davy was really cool but not
like back to the George Lucas thing like
like I was thinking about the other day
like I was jumping back home and I was
like I was like I could imagine you know
we're like we're it's literally like
them BOTS like if they bought Star Wars
on a street corner from George Lucas and
he's like hey by the way I have some
ideas like yeah send us an email it
would be like if they was if it was like
bring a fan on this set for a day and
he's like oh I have a couple of great
ideas from my fan scripts and they were
like sure thing buddy yeah like just
leave them on the desk on your way out
yeah like we were living with Susan oh
yeah it's basically like when our fans
like to go hey there's this book I know
about from 1996 that involves a subscrib
a line and I'd love it if you could do
the comic as well yeah what I'm serious
about they they rebuffed Lucas's
suggestion but but like you know like
III am in my opinion like I don't know
this I don't know if you know how its
base but it might like from what they've
revealed in the trailers it looks to me
like the whole I can every what does
call me more about like the the group
that kylo Ren is part of that ladder
they're like a group of people who like
dedicated themselves to like the idea of
Darth Vader and follow family but I mean
I don't know this may not be spoilers
but we've gathered is like he's a part
of a group that seems to it from what
I've read that is like they're like
trying to cuz I mean from what I've seen
like the Jedi can see they're pretty
much gone yeah and this is a group
trying to like live on the Sith mean
that's what it looks like as far as I
can tell on that idea
yeah you know that is an interesting
idea I mean in all its really good
because JJ Abrams said that when they
made the movies they wanted them to feel
like the original films yeah when the
original films picked up like you had to
sit and you had a Jedi and that was all
we had to Jedi yet Yoda but you didn't
find out about him until the second
movie but like even then by the time
Empire Strikes Back came back you know
you had a Padawan
Walker but you had like you know Yoda as
the last remaining Jedi you had you know
the Emperor and you had Vader and that
was it in terms of for part of my
episode three to four doesn't really
work and like no one believes the Jedi
existed you know my twenty years ago
years ago that was like an army of them
right there were a lot of them you know
they're everywhere what makes me excited
about that is maybe we'll finally get a
nice balance of Jedi stuff and the other
things that make Star Wars really cool
yeah it's all Jedi and they're all
boring yeah how could you possibly like
it's amazing your job is you get a medal
for being able to make lightsaber fights
alright because I never have expected I
would never been expected to see to be
bored of a lightsaber fight does that
episode one fight awesome all because
Rey Park played Darth mom was like this
sucks I'm gonna Ray Park it up and it's
like thank you God but then you got that
awful fight with Dooku and the other
ones and they're and they turn off the
lights came and see anything and it's
like this who cares and then and Yoda
notwithstanding and then you got like
the 45 minute long lightsaber fight with
Anakin and obi-wan that you know what
happens at the end and you're like oh my
god well this one might be like one
lightsaber one guy yeah good the rest of
spaceships and bounty hunters and lasers
and there's lasers and yeah like sorry
you were I was gonna say I find it funny
as I linked it earlier but the the how
it should have ended for episode two or
three whatever was and there's two
courses in there that I'm like like that
makes 100% more sense when he captures
Jango Fett I needs calling in and he's
like so I don't have room to carry him
back can you send help and they're like
nope so you're just gonna sit there on
your cushions while I've got this guy
yep so I'm doing all the work here
well that was C that was I was going
back and like I just finished episode
five oh I'm getting ready to start
returning the Jedi but Republic I'm
gonna like super Star Wars it up and I'm
gonna put bb-8 here put him on patrols
we're just going
wheeling around while I do it dude I was
watching those movies while writing the
script for shattered Empire and then
tomorrow
like when I'm writing the script for the
second video on shattered Empire I'm
gonna be watching them again but like
what made those movies so cool and I was
thinking about this during Empire
Strikes Back
during the scene where Anakin or where
Vader and Luke Skywalker fight and if
you go through the movies go through all
of those four or five and six there's
like five lightsaber battles right and
they're quick the first one you've got
obi-wan and you got Darth Vader the
second it's in it's an emotionally
important but it's but even I'll admit
like it's boring yeah oh yeah it's not
it's like but it wasn't but that wasn't
that was the difference is what made
those movies cool what made those movies
interesting when they the Jedi
interesting is a Jedi weren't like these
ridiculously opie you know super martial
art he Bruce Bruce Lee characters
literally disguise who could happen to
the force and knew how to use a
lightsaber and it was also the first
time you ever see a lightsaber so you're
so dazzled by the idea you're already
and it's been by the time you realize
it's boring it's over by the way did you
know that the same fight choreographer
did the fight scene in print in Princess
Bride choreographed the obi-wan Vader
fight gorilla dick yeah it was literally
just the guys from Princess Bride were
like I want to do all this cool stuff
and George is like I don't care what
happens I believe in man like but know
like there's only five and they're all
and you know but they're great yeah I
mean like the most important one is
Episode five because that's that's like
it's like Luke Skywalker's testing
ground like how far have you come in
your training and then of course you
have the significant battle and so now
there's only three there's only three
yeah the lightsaber fights it's it's
obi-wan versus Vader I'm sorry yeah
obi-wan versus Vader it's you Luke
versus Vader and then it's Luke for
sustain yeah so there's only three
there's only three like they were
fighting in the green light see my turns
on like five times in the whole trilogy
yeah and that's that's what made it so
interesting was because anything else
was focusing on like characters you know
there was and it was it was telling you
there was this great big huge expansive
universe besides like Jedi were just a
small
seven right and I agree that like
episodes one two and three took away
from now it was like there's the Jedi
and then there's this universe you know
and and it took away from like how big
the Star Wars events were I would say
that in those movies if you'd gone back
and reduced the role of the Jedi
it would have thrown like the actions of
the Emperor and everything into a far
more prominent role and it would have
made a more significant you know but the
fact remains that then that's what made
those movies cool is it was all cared
about like to me that the best scene out
of the entire you know out of all of
episodes four five and six aren't even
the lightsaber battles it's the Battle
of Hoth and it fire strikes no but I
totally like the Starfighter fights
better yeah yeah like the final battle
in Return of the Jedi
with all the so cool it was a you know
yeah I hope we get something like that
well that's as I understand that's what
Avery was shooting for is he was he was
saying like this is setting the stage
for what comes in later but the movie is
supposed to have the same kind of feel s
episode 4 and episode 5 I'm sure it'll
be the same way or I guess episode 8
it'll be like episode 5 and so on but
you know I would I would like to believe
that you know Disney recognizes the
opportunity to take a franchise that a
lot of people are kind of given up on by
the time episode 3 came out and turn it
around you know now and that's that's
that's kind of a generational gap too to
be honest because people who were
younger people who were born in 1990 and
went to go see episode 1 in 1999 you
know we're just like wow this is this is
so amazing and they grew up with Emmett
shows 1 2 & 3 they're like this is the
best Star Wars films ever are they
comment on my channel my videos people
like us who grew up in the 19 that you
know were born in the 1980s you know we
were like no those movies are not very
good because you know we we recognize
the difference we went from seeing the
first four of the episodes 4 5 & 6 and
then going into 1 2 & 3 and we can we
can spot the drastic differences between
the two but you know it'll be
interesting to see you know growing up
seeing episodes 4 5 & 6 first then
coming back and watching episodes 1 2 &
3 then sitting down in a theater and
watching episode 7 I'm curious to see
how I'll look at that film like how I'll
feel want me out of the
we're running forwarding over in time so
I want to end with one final question
here okay do you think the prequels
would have been better if the internet
existed back then to the degree that
exist now the prequels
yeah the 1 2 & 3 no I don't think so it
would be exactly the same because I was
just thinking of like if the internet
was there and cuz you get immediate
feedback now I'm telling you right now
if seven comes out and there's crap that
nobody likes to the point of like a Jar
Jar Binks oh my god well though Disney
cares George doesn't exactly George
Lucas like he fired everybody that
disagreed with him so he's not gonna
listen for a fan to listen to fans on a
message because here's here's like it's
it's call duty as a perfect example
every year call duty comes out and
people say man this game sucks this game
blows like why can't they do this why
can't well because they know you're
gonna buy it
that's why right like make a better game
with Star Wars it's the same way like
George Lucas knew the Star Wars fans are
gonna go by or they're gonna go see it
and they're gonna go see multiple times
if for no other reason to say here's how
much I hate it and here's why you know
he knew people were gonna go and see
Star Wars movies even really I don't
even think he really believed people
could not like them I think okay they
really think he was just like there's no
way connected from reality
okay question for you guys I have this
box here which versions of one of four
or five and six are in here the real
ones of the George Lucas ones gonna be a
real and they're always gonna be George
Lucas versions yep if you want to get
the real ones you're gonna to go on eBay
and pay $5,000 for the VHS laserdisc out
of the player like by the way I got
laserdisc dude we got Comic Con next
year like I want to go to your house and
we should watch like episodes four five
and six on laserdisc look literally must
be like you don't we're not even gonna
go New York there is a there's a guy out
there his name's a d1 a dy w a n or
whatever he has been trying to make
better versions of the original trilogy
using like shooting extra things and
putting in CG
from my money like it's like he only
made one because he was working he's
been working at Empire for about ten
years so it'll never come out
but he made episode four and it's crazy
cool really like it's not definitive but
it's if you want to watch an episode for
that feels like the first time you
watched it it's kinda like playing
ocarina of time like we're ago this game
was the best you sit down play it again
you're like oh look at all these
polygons and they [ __ ] updated it for
the DS look oh it's amazing like it's
like that where it's like you remember
it cuz there's that he threw in all this
extra stuff but like in a way where he's
like George Lucas could have done this
but he chose to make these really bad
decisions
yeah like when they go when they're when
they're attacking the Death Star and one
of them says here they come and then
like six typhoid ER show up and you're
like oh no you know as an adult you like
up 6 6 tie fighters
we could really destroy the entire space
nation about 6 typewriters yeah he put
in about a thousand more he put in like
always extra explosion like this looks
really awesome wow it's really cool I
was just very impressed just so many
cool decisions so you know when it comes
to like going back and making definitive
versions like listen like the old Star
Wars movies are beautiful and amazing
and if you can find them you know like
there's a thx remastered version on VHS
that came out before 1997 that has a few
changes but they're not CG changes like
you don't have horrible Jabba you don't
have you know you walks blinking or
anything stupid like you know wampas in
it it's just yeah like that like there's
a single job yeah the you know it was a
Java man it's so bad it was bad the
first time and then it was bad again
alright well I think I think that's a
good one good place to drop
run another time now so I mean any any
closing thoughts force awakens me I'm
excited I'm really hit again see what
they do with it
rob so excited he's already watching all
the movies again yeah yeah yeah Rob so
excited you will actin white oh how are
we gonna watch him again after that like
I'll watch them
I'll watch all the movies in the next
I've just put on the loop in his house
yeah like I mean I've got a very player
in my PC so I'm literally just gonna be
watching them alright guys thank you so
much for joining us with today's special
edition of the weekly poll in which we
talk about Star Wars and spoilers and
what proper etiquette is bear in mind if
you tweet Sal spoilers I'm giving the
warning now because we just had a whole
discussion about how much salad said he
will ban you and if you try to doing in
our chat here sure Sal been here too he
can ban you anywhere so I'm not a bands
like a hundred people no Chet Salvio
take that a week yeah no it's true I
really don't have the luxury of banning
people off my Twitter I only have like
24 this people are people are making
pizzas of HUD references in the chat
we're not gonna be here next week it is
Christmas week so we will see you in two
weeks
New Year's no wait a minute now when is
New Year's Eve that's a product oh it's
a product that's what Thursday Thursday
it's not Tuesday just next week I'm
taking the whole week off of everything
so okay yeah okay I was gonna be like uh
I will not be in any condition to your
podcast topics and coffee you I
guarantee you will see a periscope hot
again aren't it on that note I'll see
you guys later peace